you are uh quite the athlete I'm told is
this uh no I'm not I was told you hold a
record in the state of Oregon oh that is
true yeah that's amazing
we held a record knew we could do with
the record his birth yes I am I was a
member of a high school basketball team
that broke the Oregon state record for
consecutive losses
USA USA you somehow extrapolated yeah um
I was not even good enough to start on
this team I was on the bench this is the
record you set the record for Moses and
you were on the bench I was on the bench
uh as we were getting close to the
record uh the newspapers kind of got a
hold of the story and we're you know
sort of excited not a lot happening in
Southern Oregon and started to kind of
count it down a little bit so there was
a little bit of pressure on us and so
our school decided to give us a ceremony
for enduring the state's longest losing
streak so they they they they held a
ceremony in school where they had us all
come up on stage and receiveth we were
the Mustangs a Mustang pride pin so just
in case anybody didn't know who were the
but the losers in school you could just
point up on stage of each of the people
getting a pin this is this is the
sickest pony or you've been the lion so
it could be a big L Govan air Oh how's
your L um we hadn't even broken the
record yet we we finally broke the
record the pressure is off we were
losing his semen in basketball but Noah
gentlemen uh phoned into the newspaper
to say no they actually didn't break the
record for consecutive losses my team in
the sixteenth broke the record for
consecutive losses and that man was my
uncle was apparently so competitive he
didn't want to lose at losing and so
then we proceeded to continue to lose
because we didn't want to lose the
losing thing yeah you might as well go
all the way oh we went all the way we
continued to lose we broke that record
ladies and gentlemen yeah
yeah good for you until finally they
brought in a motivational speaker who
was very very like uncannily predated
Chris Farley's van down by the river
yeah yeah the river he was a
weightlifter who came in in the sort of
like you know the 80s like a barely tied
sweatshirt at the shoulder like that
thing kind of screamed at us for a half
an hour before the game was leading
right up to the game to inspire you to
inspire us to win and we were kind of
getting into it and right at the end he
said I have never won a single
weightlifting tournament in my life but
I have never given up we all went out uh
we went out got into the layup line he
stood underneath the basket and his big
giant kind of loving arms was sort of
catching us and then sending us back out
in the layup line that don't I don't
know I don't I don't want to think too
deeply about what was going on there and
no one had hired him he just showed yeah
yeah I'll I'm here to touch all the kids
come on in back back I've got my own
method as you'll see and we went on to
play that game it was the first game I
ever started I scored two points in that
game
two crucial free throws midway through
the first quarter and that's when the
crucial points all right left ball
that's if you talk to anybody who knows
basketball yeah they say midway through
the first quarter if you get to the line
hit them both yeah or you're in trouble
and we won the game you won the game
guys you want
yeah
you